what does it feel like when a man
penetrates you can you explain it in a
way
where men can understand oh boy
[Applause]
[Music]
did your first time hurt i do remember
it being a pleasant experience
but it was painful and i was sore for
like
days after no it didn't hurt at all
actually it was really careful about it
and he made sure
to ask me if it did hurt or not yeah i
wasn't used to have any having anything
in my vagina like i didn't even use
tampons at the time
i ended up bleeding anything like that
it was like very great
we did it it was done we got burritos
after it's very enjoyable
i wish there was some sort of education
on like more the emotional side because
after
like my first it took me so long to even
like
kiss anyone again just because it felt
very odd to me because this was like
something that had been reserved for one
person for a very
long time and like i was trying to
navigate
like dating and relationships and i felt
like i couldn't have a normal
relationship because
any man coming on to me even if that's
what the setting was even if it's
something that i would have wanted to do
it just felt
wrong to me what does it feel like when
a man penetrates you
can you explain it in a way where men
can understand
oh boy oh that's so weird
what is it i'm gonna try my best
for a man when you really
have the urge to go to the bathroom
that feeling that like relief except for
it's the reverse
you don't like feel it in one spot it
kind of like
you feel it you know when you have to
like you put like a
like a lid on something it's like oddly
satisfying when you put a lid on a jar
of pickles
and did i really just describe it as
that
do you ever worry your vagina doesn't
look normal
yes i felt like i didn't have a normal
vagina
not anymore i definitely did at one
point because then i would hear like
this whole rhetoric about like
roast beef or whatever and i was like my
vagina kind of does look like roast beef
and i don't know why that's a problem
if you're on birth control how does it
affect your body so it's not something
i'm currently on but when i was on it it
i believed that it was clear my acne
because that's something i heard for a
long time
but it did the complete opposite it made
it worse i for sure had mood swings and
i feel like that's not
who i am at all it might take you
several different
tries with birth control to find one
that works for your body for me
i loved maneuvering my sister tried
maneuvering
she gained like 15 pounds and hated it
the main thing is to make sure you're
always taking it because
i have a tendency to forget and that's
when it really messes you up
with the implant um i bled for almost a
year straight
so that wasn't fun at all if you have
any like questions just talk to a doctor
about it
sex on your period how ah
in all caps ah um never have i ever
well i did have my period for a year
straight
so that's something i had to figure out
you gotta use a towel
and a condom honestly it feels better
because
your hormones are so all over the place
that
it's kind of it's it's not as it's not
as bad as everyone thinks it is
personally to me sex on my period just
seems uncomfortable because i'm already
cramping up
a lot you're already really sensitive by
your vagina
things like diva cups and different
types of
period products per se that can go
inside of you and you can have
mess free that's how they advertise it
mess free
period sex is it normal to masturbate i
know some people who would say
no it's not and i disagree
wholeheartedly i feel like people who
are like i don't mess around i don't
watch i don't do anything
that builds up and i feel like
masturbation is a way to kind of let it
out
i do it probably every day have you ever
questioned your sexuality
yes i went through like a whole
questioning phase like
would i ever really be attracted to
another woman i think that's very normal
for people to go through
even just like coming to terms with the
fact that you're straight
i had one very strong crush on a girl
but i think it was more of an
but just the way she looked i wanted to
look like her more so than be with her
have you ever had an orgasm i have not
yes yes nope
growing up especially during puberty
there was sort of like this feeling of
shame tagged around girls
um going through puberty and feeling
horny like if i felt a little horny i
was like oh no like this isn't normal
if i'm horny i just sit through it and i
don't do anything about it and i wait
till it passes
but because of that like later in my
body like just
when it's like about to orgasm my body
like shuts down it's like no you're not
gonna
that's and that's just my mind blocking
it
which something i'm working on
have you ever faked an orgasm hmm
one time in my early days
because i felt so bad
[Laughter]
but never again i felt like a shame that
i was taking too long
you kind of have this expectation that
you're gonna act like the girls in the
pornos is it important to find a partner
that
can make you orgasm if they can't make
you orgasm
at first i think you should find a
partner who's willing to
learn and adjust to what you want so
that you both can
have a better time and i think if they
learn to adjust to what you like then
their partner worth having a round of
nets that's the partner you want to have
sex with
for so long i was with partners i mean
for five or six years when i was first
having sex i was with partners again and
again
that never made me orgasm but i also
didn't know how to make myself orgasm
so i wasn't masturbating i wasn't
communicating with my partners i didn't
know what positions were turn-ons for me
i had to have a conversation with him
because i'm like i'm lying i'm lying to
me i'm lying to him
the whole experience just could be so
much better and so i remember
he was laying in bed we had the
conversation
and he was saying he's like oh my gosh
i'm so sorry so
it's not necessarily important for me to
be with a partner that makes me orgasm
but it is important for me to be with a
partner that prioritizes my pleasure
do you feel like you mostly just
accommodate men and what they want
during sex i definitely get like nervous
in the sense of like am i performing
well am i doing a good job
at first yes as i started to
be with more people i started to realize
i started to ask well what do you want
me to do what do you like and i was like
what do i like that's i don't know
what do you consider assault or rape i
think i may have been
but i don't exactly know
[Music]
i know a lot of people are taught rape
or assault is this big scary aggressive
thing
it could be something like with someone
you're
really comfortable with or someone you
considered yourself to trust
is it okay if i talk about an assault
because like my first time was like a
coercion
kind of situation i knew at some point
i wanted to do it with that person but i
just didn't feel like i was ready
per se and i was pressured into it which
was something that like
we're not really taught taught about
like coercion and stuff like that in
school and
really the depth of consent so i didn't
really have the understanding like i
just because i did say yes eventually
and it did
end up going that way that that's not
okay
so many of us have this question
i've had very personal conversations
with dear friends who
didn't come to terms with the fact that
they had been assaulted or raped until
five or six years later if you can
afford or if your insurance covers it
get some professional
advice and guidance on this because this
is a
question that really needs to be talked
about more
and then last question what is something
that you wish
you learned in success that girls
masturbated
the range of consent and what is no i
wish i was taught more about
sex not being such a shameful thing for
women
[Applause]
[Music]
you